all right now i'm going to give you an
example of how
easy it has become to fine-tune a
language model on your specific
tasks and and i'm gonna
run some music if that's okay to get in
the mood
all right so uh by uh setting up the
environment here in collab um
for this experiment we're going to
leverage the project of
fantastic community contributor boris
dima
called hugging tweets as described the
goal is to
train a language model to write new
tweets
based on your own unique voice in just
five minutes here you can see that the
environment has been set up uh correctly
so we'll
pick a twitter handle for the data set
unfortunately
jensen the ceo of nvidia doesn't have a
twitter account so we'll use
the generic nvidia account
for this experiment now it's uh
starting to download the nvidia tweets
by scrapping twitter
all right here we got some of the
tweets from the nvidia
twitter account and it's created a
data set only keeping 1348
tweets from it so now that we gathered
the data set
we'll be able to start training the
neural network
keep in mind that we're not initializing
weights from scratch
but leveraging an existing model coming
with own weights
and just fine tuning them here we're
using the great gpt2
created by openai as the language model
learned a lot from pre-training two
thousand three
hundred tweets or are necessary also
that's why it's extremely fast it just
takes a few minutes to
to train that's the power of transfer
learning that we were
talking about earlier for the compute we
have to thank google who's providing the
free gpus in
good apps also thanks to
tools like weights and biases you can
follow how your loss is involving your
learning rate
depending on the earpods it's a really
great
tool to use
all right let's wait for a minute or two
for the model to
finish training
all right it's uh finished training and
now it's
blowing the model to hugging face so
it's been
fast
all right the new network has been
successfully trained
now right away you can go into the
hugging face model hub and
you'll find the model right here
so keep in mind that the model is
trained on the tweets
from nvidia so maybe what we can try it
with
is uh the future
of tech is
all right here as you can see the model
hasn't
been loaded yet it might take a
little bit of time for this to happen
we'll just wait and see
if it gets loaded all right now the
model
has been loaded and as you can see
it's starting generating the future of
tech
is bright that makes sense i'm pretty
much on brand
let's uh start something else maybe
all right the future of tech is changing
a lot with tech giant such as tesla
nvidia read more about these three major
companies along with their plans for ai
and deep learning on our blog
pretty cool and as you can see the
inference time is pretty low with just
uh over a second
on cpus not only can you
test the predictions here but you can
also take advantage of our
api to integrate these predictions
into your products in a matter of
minutes will
run the inference and the predictions
for you
if you prefer to host it yourself
you can just use these a few lines
here changing the name of the model in
transformers to be able to run that in
in a matter of
minutes too in addition you'll find on
the model pages
all the informations you need to pick
and understand the right model
so here you see like how does it work
you can see like the training data
the training procedure and for example
useful things like intending
uses and limitations
the beauty of the hugging face model hub
is that not only can you use your own
model
but you can also use any
of the more than 3 000 models that have
been pre-trained
and shared by the community
you can obviously filter them by
framework
pi torch or tensorflow based on the
tasks
you're interested in text specification
token classification
question sharing multiple choice
civilization translation conversational
and also by uh languages
maybe i can show you another example of
a task here with
summarization using a model that has
been uploaded by
facebook and trade on the data sets
extracted from
cnn what it's doing is taking
a wikipedia page here of the efl tower
and generating a summary of it
it's pretty cool because it's a very new
task
and this model is state of the art on
this task
of summarization maybe let's take
another task that is a bit simpler
for example token classification
you can see here that this model is
extracting
entities and information from text here
it's detecting that wolfgang is a person
and that berlin is a location
also as you can see it's extremely fast
on
cpus i wanted to give you
a couple more examples of things that
are starting to work well
for example zero shot
topic classification and and maybe take
uh
a custom example here uh let's say you
incoming customer support emails and you
wanna
classify based on their priority what
you have to do is just
define these levels pretty high
priority low and right away even if the
model hasn't seen these labels
it's going to be able to try to play
predict the classification
so like for example a customer is
sending an email like that it's very
urgent i need
your help asp
here is going to try classifies as you
can see
it detects that the priority of such
a message is really high it's really
cool here that you can pick
any uh topic any label any
classification
that you want even if the model hasn't
been trained on that
another really really cool advancement
that we've seen over the past few months
is the ability to do long-form question
answering
especially in open domain and when you
need to pull up from different
forces so for example here to question
what's the best way to treat a sunburn
the model is taken from different
articles from wikipedia
and generating an answer itself and
maybe we can try
it with something else for example
how do you make coffee
all right
all right you take a cup of coffee grind
them put them unfiltered and you eat a
beans let them
keep the water process is called coffee
roasting
pretty accurate and you can see again
it's picking up
a couple of like different articles from
wikipedia
there are also links right
you can go further it's a great way to
give
explainabilities to your users
alright that's pretty much it just to
finish obviously all of it is
powered by our open source that you can
find
on github transformers
that is pretty well known today that is
the most popular
open source nlp library with more than
34 000
gita stars used by
thousands of companies and more than 500
contributors you'll also find on github
our other repositories
the two biggest ones being tokenizers
for
fast tokenization and data sets
to find open data sets that you can use
for free and metrics to access your
models all right that's pretty much it
thanks everyone
my